the story of ant-man and the washed as
told by Luiz I first met Scotty in cell
by D and I was like unbelief and he says
I'm Scotty and we're gonna be best
friends
this guy's gets out of jail and that's
when he met hope look at my hair dude
I'm all business
[Applause]
but things got he's like I'm gonna go
trash an Arab over captain america kappa
needed help to america and then she said
he's gonna screw up again and would
everything awesome if only cap could see
you now the only chance we've got
there's supposed to be one of the things
that I really like about playing this
character is he is thrown into these
extraordinary circumstances shrinking
flying around the hands entering quantum
realms and life-threatening stuff one
thing that we've always tried to sustain
is dealing with everything with a little
bit of us as a few right we have a lot
of tricks in this movie that the
audience hasn't seen before you will see
ant-man size action and giant size
action and you may see a lot of
different size action in between I get
Jeff how was school today and then you
have wasp she's someone that we've never
seen in action on screen and that's been
great in terms of figuring out how she
moves how she fights how she flies
you gave her wings and blasters so I
take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
there's so much action and the stakes
are so high
immediately the minute that we introduce
the character of ghosts the game changes
what's up you so long she just wanted to
give me a hug wish me luck really don't
stop moving
wish I had a suit even with like minimal
powers or maybe even just a suit with no
powers no hey everybody it's Charlie so
we got some new ant-man and the wasp
obviously it's dropping in theaters this
week so I'll explain what my video
schedule is gonna be for the rest of my
ant-man videos at the end of the video
but we also found out some really cool
deleted scenes from infinity war and
going all the way back to Civil War
apparently there used to be a whole lot
more ant-man in the wasp plan for some
of these movies than they've changed so
it's always cool to hear about deleted
scenes and the alternate ideas that the
writers had so we do have a clip from
the infinity war riders that I'll
include in this but if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos we got
comic-con coming up in a couple weeks
and there's that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway that's going on all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video but let's
start with the footage first obviously
they had that funny scene with Michael
Pena doing the same thing he did during
the first movie where he explains things
there was the version of that clip that
they played way back at comic-con last
year where he in Paul Rudd were
explaining the history of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe to Janet Van Dyne
because she come out of the quantum room
so she'd missed all the events of all
the Marvel movies that had happened so
it was just a funny way to recap the
Marvel Cinematic Universe doing it the
Michael Pena way I sincerely hope that
we have a version of that when we get to
Avengers 4 because that really is meant
to be a book end of an era of Marvel
films before they move on to the next 20
plus films but we've got to the point in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe where they
make the same type of videos that I make
where they're like wow there's all this
stuff that's happened and a lot of
people don't know everything so we're
gonna have to recap it so they don't get
lost when they walk into the theater no
spoilers for ant-man and the wasp but
Michael Pena steals every scene that
he's in I hope they keep him around for
a long long time I don't know if they
plan to make another Ant Man of the wasp
film I think it just depends on how this
one does financially I think it'll do
great it'll probably make more money
than the first film which merited a
sequel so therefore I suppose you could
justify another ant-man in the wasp film
but what they might choose to do is just
put them in someone else's film or doula
thor ragnarok style crossover where you
have wasp teaming up with someone else
because Evangeline Lilly has already
started talking about NATO now that I'm
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and we
have a really badass version of the wasp
who do you want to team up with she says
she really wants to do a movie with the
Hulk and while Marvel can't make a
genuine Hulk solo film you could put
them in someone else's film too but just
be thinking about that in the back of
your mind as you go to see the movie
this week or whenever you do get around
to seeing ant-man of the wasp where do
you want these characters to pop up next
besides Avengers 4 what'll happen is is
there's like a lot of stuff for the
future that I can't talk about till I
get to the spoiler videos later this
week so we'll wait to talk about what
happens next with these characters after
everybody has a chance to see the movie
but the really cool story is as deleted
scenes so apparently there was a time
when ant-man the wasp we're gonna be
included in infinity war but it was the
ant-man and the wasp director who pulled
them out and was like no no no like
we're gonna have our own solo movie so
let's not bother to put them in this so
there was a draft where you touch base
with ant-man the wasp like they have a
couple moments in the script where they
say they're under house arrest or when
they reference Hawkeye before everybody
turns to dust so you just have to
imagine a version of events where
ant-man is standing in the background of
all these big crowd shots not doing a
whole lot till we get to Avengers 4 so
we think they made the right call of
splitting a lot of the characters
between the two films so we just have to
wait to Avengers 4 to find out which of
those deaths that they roll back because
they said that some of them would be
permanent the other real cool deleted
scene is that they revealed that they
were originally gonna introduce the wasp
character hopes wasp character during
Civil War but the director of a man the
wasp was like we wouldn't have enough
time to do her justice so let's pull her
out so these are the infinity war riders
talking about that so it starts with
Kevin Feige leaning his head into their
riders room where they're sitting with
the Russos breaking the story and he
whispers spider-man and then disappears
like a fairy so what what if you can
tell us what is the non spider-man
version of Civil War look like oh good
Oh buddy yelled he probably recruits a
man I think would be that idea what is
it well we had we had a section where
you could recruit somebody right
actually went to San Francisco got it
would have been like San Francisco and
yeah Queen that's right yeah what
nothing as cool I believe he was
watching his daughter play soccer it
wasn't very good who came up with the
idea of the mentor relationship we did
although yeah we did but the Downey when
you when Tom gets in a room with Robert
Downey jr. it is the relationship right
it's a young actor with the seasoned
actor doesn't want to [ __ ] up you know
like there's so many it's about three or
four lines in that bedroom scene that
are just Downey you know as I move the
leg I got to sit here and that's just
you know it was literally telling ya
this is the part we like like he's this
magic fairy that just grants you special
big huge characters there's gonna be a
version of that with the x-men
characters in a couple years too he'll
just walk in and whisper x-men and then
just disappear into the night I think in
retrospect it was probably the right
idea that they just saved wasp for
ant-man in the wasp but they were gonna
do her justice so when you get a chance
to see it let me know what you guys
think of the movie what'll happen is is
I'll do a spoiler review probably
Thursday or Friday then I'll do a
post-credits scene video talk about the
ending then I'll talk about the future
Avengers force stuff everything going
forward with these characters if for
some reason they're delaying the release
of the movie in your country don't worry
the videos will be there for you to come
back and watch there'll be a whole bunch
more Marvel Captain Marvel Avengers
force stuff happening for the rest of
the summer in Tom Holland actually just
showed up on the set of spider-man far
from home so just expect a lot of that
Spider Man sequel stuff to be dropping
this summer too and it should be pretty
cool congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner rasli 85 please private
message me so I can get your contact
details
everybody click here to learn more about
the Avengers 4 title and click here to
learn more about the first episode of
DC's Titans coming to that streaming
service thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you
tonight
[Music]